[Music]
like five and this was probably probably
around the 6 yeah Camila Cabello bold in
blue at the 2018 MTV Video Music Awards
Jennifer Lopez is getting the video
Vanguard Award tonight and she's the
first Latin artist to ever do so what
does that mean to you I didn't know that
I didn't know she was the first Latin
artist ever to win the award it's so
amazing and she just I mean it you can
tell this she's so besides me extremely
talented you can tell that she just is
an incredibly hard worker she honors her
roots she's so proud of being a Latin
woman and people like her that have
paved the way for girls like me and
Latin girls all over the world that have
a dream and come from a place that they
don't know if that's possible you know
she's the perfect example of somebody
that's a role model for people like that
so I also just saw maluma I go and
inside fortune I was just telling my mom
like it makes me excited to have like to
have like Latin energy here tonight it
makes me feel good
how's your energy level because you've
been incredibly busy house tour life
everything I've been really great I've
honestly had to take a lot of deep
breaths in this red carpet because it's
just like it's just it's insane like the
amount of energy I mean also the fact
that it's New York
I feel like contributes to it but I'm
really excited I have my mom sitting
with me because I was like I just came
food from Miami this morning and I was I
was home for a few days for the first
time and like I don't even like since
high school so so I was just I'm really
excited to have my mom here and where
I'm not performing so I'm just gonna get
like kind of wine drunk and hopefully
like not die during a fight if I win
they're a highlight of this year you've
had this incredible debut album for
yourself smash heads the tour with
Taylor I mean
they're something that sits out there
and is like this is the moment I won't
ever forget well I think that I think
this I feel like I've just gotten to
know myself really well this year and
besides like everything that I've you
know the amazing things that have
happened in my career I feel like I just
feel really I just feel really like
appreciative of being able to like live
and I feel like I just know what's
important in in life right now so I'm
just I'm really happy and I feel very I
don't I feel like really in touch with
my emotions which is which is good
[Music]
[Applause]